satoshi empezó a estudiar la manera en
la que el número de ramas de su árbol
aumenta a lo largo del tiempo la
relación entre el tiempo transcurrido t
en años desde que esa tos y empezó a
estudiar el árbol y el número de ramas
en el dtm se modela con la siguiente
función y aquí está la función completa
la siguiente oración sobre la tasa de
crecimiento de las ramas el número de
ramas se triplica cada espacio en blanco
años y bueno observa que aquí está el
tiempo y el tiempo está dado en años así
que qué te parece si hacemos una pequeña
tabla por aquí para que veas qué está
pasando con el tiempo déjame poner por
aquí el tiempo por aquí
nt
y vamos a hacer nuestra tabla voy a
poner por aquí nuestra tabla bien qué
pasa cuando te vale 0 bueno cuando te
vale 0 observa que esto de aquí se hace
0 y entonces tengo 24 por 3 elevado a la
potencia 0 pero 13 elevado a la potencia
0 es 1 y por lo tanto solamente me queda
24 de lujo ahora si yo quiero que este
24 se tripliquen eso quiere decir que
necesito ver en qué tiempo voy a tener
24 por 3 estoy buscando en qué momento
este 24 se va a triplicar y bueno se va
a triplicar cuando se multiplique por 3
y para multiplicar por 3 lo que necesito
es tener aquí al 3 a la primera potencia
estás de acuerdo
3 la primera potencia es 3 y entonces
estaría triplicando dicho otra manera lo
que busco es ver en qué momento esto de
aquí me va a dar 1 para que así tenga el
3 elevado la primera potencia
y bueno aquí se puede ver que cuando el
tiempo vale 15 años esto de aquí va a
valer 1 porque 15 entre 15 me da 1 por
lo tanto cuando te vale 15 esto me va a
quedar 24 por 3 elevado a la primera
potencia ahora de igual manera si
quisiera saber cuándo se va a volver a
triplicar de nuevo
bueno pues tendría que aumentar otros 15
años es decir si me fijo entre de 30
años bueno cuanto vale mi función cuando
te vale 30 años si observas aquí tendría
24 que va a multiplicar a quién
bueno pues observa que 30 entre 15 es 2
y va a multiplicar a 3 elevado al
cuadrado o dicho otra manera va a
multiplicar a 3 que va a multiplicar a
su vez a 3 y aquí otra vez estamos
triplicando la cantidad de ramas
anterior así que podemos decir que el
número de ramas se triplica cada 15 años
es decir cada 15 años vas a tener el
tryp
más que tenías anteriormente y bueno
todo esto sale de la definición de la
función aquí tenemos a este 15
involucrado pero siempre es bueno tener
una tabla para razonar un poco más y ver
con calma qué es lo que está sucediendo
muy bien qué te parece si hacemos uno
más y para eso déjame bajar la pantalla
y vamos a trabajar con el siguiente
problema voy a poner este de aquí dice
cameron envió un mensaje en cadena a sus
amigos y les pidió que le enviaran a más
amigos la relación entre el tiempo
transcurrido tema en días desde que
cameron envió la carta y el número de
personas
pdte que recibe el mensaje se modela con
la siguiente función y aquí la tenemos
completa la siguiente oración sobre la
tasa de cambio del número de personas
que recibe el mensaje cada espacio en
blanco
díaz el número de personas que recibe el
mensaje crece un 83% adicional
esta vez nos dice que crece un 83%
adicional en esta ocasión nos están
dando cuánto crece o decrece en un
porcentaje y si tenemos que crecer un 83
por ciento adicional eso quiere decir
que vamos a ir aumentando nuestro número
de personas dicho de otra manera esto
quiere decir esto es exactamente lo
mismo que multiplicar por un factor de
1.83 otra forma de verlo sería pensar en
cuánto tiempo vamos a tener un número de
personas 1.83 veces mayor que el número
de personas que teníamos anteriormente
eso es lo mismo que pensar que la
función crece en un 83% adicional y
bueno si observas aquí tenemos al 1.83
involucrado entonces podemos ver la
función y ver que vamos a usar este 2.5
o bueno en su dado caso si quieres
podemos hacer una
inestable por aquí que nos diga la
solución una pequeña tabla muy parecida
a la que hicimos en el ejercicio
anterior
voy a tener aquí al tiempo y por aquí a
apt ok y cuando el tiempo vale cero
bueno esto se hace uno y solamente me
quedo con 100 estás de acuerdo sólo me
quedo con 100 ahora en qué tiempo vamos
a tener a 100 x 1 punto 83 y bueno
quiero multiplicar por 1 punto 83 porque
en este momento lo que estamos haciendo
es creciendo en un 83 por ciento
adicional déjame ponerlo así voy a
aumentar aquí un 83 por ciento adicional
muy bien y bueno en qué tiempo tengo
esto bueno eso es exactamente lo mismo
que pensar en 100 que multiplica a 1.83
elevado a la primera potencia y bueno
para eso lo que queremos es hacer
exponente 1 y entonces para qué tiempo
en días este exponente se va a ser 1 y
bueno se va a ser 1 cuando te valga 2.5
entonces cada 2.5 días el número de
personas que recibe el mensaje crece un
83 por ciento adicional puedes estar muy
tentado a que cada uno de estos
ejercicios pongas este número que
tenemos como denominador y así
encuentras la respuesta pero eso no te
va a servir de nada por eso te encargo
que analices y pienses un poco cada uno
de estos problemas que pienses por qué
está sucediendo todo esto si solo de
manera automática pones este número de
aquí no sé qué tanto te sirva para
aprender pero bueno hagamos uno más voy
a hacer uno más y va a ser este que
tengo acá abajo rosario es una
ecologista que estudia los cambios en la
población de pingüinos en la antártica a
lo largo del tiempo la relación entre el
tiempo transcurrido
en años desde que rosario empezó a
estudiar la población y el número de
pingüinos en el tema se modela con la
siguiente función completa la siguiente
oración sobre la tasa de cambio de la
población de pingüinos la población de
pingüinos pierde 3 séptimos de su tamaño
cada espacio en blanco años y ojo aquí
está la clave la población de pingüinos
pierde 3 séptimos de su tamaño cada un
cierto tiempo de años ahora cuando se
pierden 3 séptimos de su tamaño eso
quiere decir déjame ponerlo con este
color eso quiere decir que nos vamos a
quedar con 4 séptimos es más déjame
ponerlo así perder 3 séptimos
d
3 séptimos es lo mismo que multiplicar
y carl por 4 séptimos por 4 séptimos
porque cada vez que nosotros
multiplicamos por 4 séptimos estamos
perdiendo 3 séptimos del total si
tuviera 7 pingüinos y perdiera tres
pingüinos bueno pues voy a quedar
solamente con cuatro pingüinos así que
perder 3 séptimos de su tamaño de la
población de pingüinos es lo mismo que
multiplicar que multiplicar por 4
séptimos así que vamos a multiplicar por
4 séptimos y observa que aquí ya tenemos
la razón común aquí ya tenemos la razón
común y entonces cada vez que este valor
de aquí se haga un entero entonces vamos
a multiplicar por 4 séptimos y eso va a
suceder cuando tengamos múltiplos de 3 o
dicho otra manera la población de
pingüinos va a perder 3 séptimos de su
tamaño cada 3
cada 3
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo